hello everyone and welcome to the final
round or the OtterBox Nova championship
it's Fabiano Carano vs. magnus carlsen
and of course it's a very exciting
matchup as the two of them played the
World Chess Championship match in London
last year and none of the class pro
games of course they played the ended in
a decisive result all the 12 games ended
in a draw so it's very interesting what
will happen here again I will not say
this is classical or or or the
Armageddon you will just have to you
know guess so without further ado let's
check it out crow wanna with the white
pieces opens with E for with c5 by
Carlson so the the Sicilian defense
everyone was interested will we see a
repetition of some of the lines from the
World Chess Championship with Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and now we don't have d4
but rather Bishop to b5 determined
universally more variation with g6 and
now Bishop captures on c6 with D
captures on c6 and d3 and Crossing goes
for Bishop to g7 following the line he
already played in this exact same
tournament against Lebanon in round 2
although there was an Armageddon game
which cross and was able to win with the
black pieces h3 by karana
again following the game again starting
on e5 with castles by Fabi Quintus e7
and now in the game against Aragon
Aragon played Bishop to e3 that did not
end well for 11 but here Fabi plays a 3
it's not a new move but it was played
only once by Croatian international
master melon mirja in 2002 and he was
able to win a very nice game with this
move but never was it played in such a
top-tier competition so night to have
six crossing continues like in the game
mentioned from 2002 but in that game b4
was played here Fabi goes for Bishop to
e3 it's a new move and it is now as of
Moon landed we have a completely new
game so Carson has to deal with this his
pawn is under attack so he just deals
with it in the more most casual way he
just advanced c4 of course white is not
interested in capturing it you would
mess up your pawn structure so a very
nice way of getting rid of it just
capturing on d3 Fabi continues
development we have C captures on d3
Queen captures and now casts by Carlsen
and that rook f2
one Fabi wants to bring this rook over
to to d2 and then bring this rook over
to d1 and have this nice rook rook Queen
battery along with the D file with rook
to e8 by Carlsen defending the e5 pawn
one more time but also as fabi's
planning to get his Bishop over to d6
Carson wants to counter it by playing
Bishop crea fate so also freeing the
effects were for the Bishop Bishop to c5
by Fabi and now across and just counters
at will Bishop to f8 Bishop capture
screen captures and of course rook to d2
continuing with the plan of bringing the
rook over to d1 Bishop to e6 cross and
also wants to bring the rook over to the
D file with rook 81 and now rook a to d8
and here
Fabi has to decide what to do the thing
is if he moves the Queen Lady Queen e3
leads to a very long draw draw draw on
line because after we get captures
captures then cousin can play Queen b6
which forces a trade of Queens as the B
to pawn is under attack
so after Queen captures pawn captures
now again it's very hard to push for
advantage here if you capture on e5 you
get Bishop captures and h3 opens up an
attack here now you don't want to give
up the night for nothing so let's say
characters captures after captures here
you will get captures and after rook d7
check King e6 rook captures here you
will get captures captures and now after
locate you will just capture everything
and then it's well you can go check here
King d7 rookies under attack rook c4 you
will go after the c2 pawn and once you
eliminate that pawn yes you are up on
but it's a well known drawn endgame so
it's not a problem
fob is not interested in making such a
draw so instead he decides to give up
the Queen for two rooks with Queen
captures and e8 rook captures rook
captures with check now you could go
King these seven crafts and decides King
g7 is better and now we have looked back
to d3 it would be dangerous to leave the
rooks so far apart as black can play
some tricky moves like Bishop d5 closing
up you know the defense of the rooks or
or even Bishop to d7 which forces the
rook here and then the rook will be so
somewhat hard to defend after b5 the
Queen will guard upon here you will be
able to tag drop for the Queen b7 so not
all that enjoyable so after King g7 with
rook back to D 3 by Fabi and now comes
h6 taking away the g5 Square from the
night also preparing some expansion on
the Kings side with B 4 by 5 e and mount
a 5 crossing once the start attacking on
the on the Queen side and take the game
over to the you know after the pawns are
exchanged on the Queen side take the
game over to the Kings side we have
worked
III and now comes Knight to d7 just Rema
nuvaring the night we have Knight to a4
and now just pushing it back nice to be
- and now comes c5 c3 defending the pawn
here and now c4 nicely blocking the
position here it will be somewhat hard
for fo beat again table brooks and e on
the D file with rook to be 2 now and 8
captures and V for a capture some before
and a knight back to f6
of course the putting pressure on this
pawn here maybe the bishop can also help
out with an attack against the e4 pawn
but other than that maybe even aside the
ideas like 9h 5 to 8 f4 will become
possible with Knights to d1 by Fabi not
sure if it's any sort of a plan or
anything but maybe just waiting to see
what Coulson will do maybe just the
ideas bringing the knight back back back
and forth with Bishop to c6 Bishop to d7
going for Bishop to c6 Knight to h2 and
now Queen to a7 putting pressure and
rope here but also the ideas you just
want to go to a 3 or a 1 at increase the
activity of your queen
Fabia can just try repeating moves but
he decides to play actively with h4
Bishop to c6
now again attacking the pawn here and
now as far be made preparations the
defendant f3 with Bishop back to d7
now again remembering the Bishop Knight
to f1 and now Bishop to e6
with King to h2 and out knife to h5
going for this very nice at Foursquare
which Fabi of course doesn't allow we
have g3 now comes g5 h captures we have
h captures and now Knight to F do but
cousin is prepared for this
advances the pond all the way we have G
for night captures and G for Bishop
captures and now F captors in g4 and now
that the pawn structure has been
somewhat ruined night back to f6 going
after the g4 pawn we have King to g2 not
allowing this capture to come with check
so Knight captures and now Luke back to
f3 now for the moment fob is not able to
double up rooks and the F file to cause
some problems here as the knight is
covering the f2 pawn but you know very
soon and here crossing has to decide
what if he wants to go Queen a8 or queen
2 a1 if he goes Quinta a1 which is very
interesting then you get Knights the e3
and then Quinta a1 just attacking the
rook here Knight to a5 check and now
King to f6 nights the d4 opening up our
discovery King back to g6 and now that
the night is controlling D 2 square now
we save the rope with rook to eat -
Quinta c1 and now your knight is still
under attack so night at 5 but now Queen
d1 and it is a very interesting position
black probably sorry about that somewhat
better but hard to say if if black can
actually push for anything here Knight
to h4 check King g7 now rook to a to
going for for some back rank ideas hard
to say well regardless Magnus doesn't
like it he was rook to Queen 288 again
puts pressure on d4 pawn queen to e2
short rope to e 2 and now kink the g6
constant starts bringing the King into
the game we've looked to f5 not allowing
the King to go any further and now f6
just further protecting the pawn here
night - each - offering a trade of
knights and now if you just trade it
then you allow rook to f2 and it will be
very hard for for black keep any chances
life here so cross and just moves the
knight and now first you have to react
to your knight and a5 being under attack
with rook to f1 keeping the option of
rook to have to open and now kink the g7
by Magnus now first rook to d1
trying to go for rook to be 7 as now the
black king is somewhat exposed but now
Queen 283 going for the c3 pawn and here
rook
d7 with check King to g6 and now well
you could the defend would rock the sea
to this pawn the Queen would just kick
it away and then capture so Fabi doesn't
feel like wasting time with Knight to f3
by Fabi and now just Queen captures on
c3 but now a father will try to create a
mating net around a Magnus King with
night stage 4 with check King to h5 and
now just to look to h7 and here the idea
is just the Knight to a5 which would
just attack the pin piece if you allow
this it's not gonna be good for you but
also there are some very interesting
ideas for example King to g4 is very
interesting because it it it will allow
me to capture here the problem is after
rook captures your Queen captures here
you will go king h1 and now you don't
have any good continuation check you can
go here and now you don't you no longer
have any checks because you just lose
the Queen and the game so cross are not
interested he goes Queen to d3 attacks
the rook here and prepares to advance
his pawn here we've looked at he won by
Fabi and here here cross and probably
could have gone for King to g4 because
now you can't capture this if you
capture them Queen d2 check pics of the
rook so here we would probably see a
draw a repetition King g7 check King
King h5 Rock h7 and and so on and so on
because Knight f5 is still a threat but
here with only a minute or maybe even
less than a minute on the clock Magnus
played c3 started pushing his past pawn
and this simply doesn't work it's a
losing move but it's really really a
crazy idea
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move for Fabi in
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds while I have a nice sip of my
water for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent supporter of disgusting engine
lines and for those who just want to
enjoy a show the point is crossing
allowed Knight f5 here which is the idea
but he allowed it thinking that he had a
rubber repetition after rook to Queen to
d2 the problem is we have to check both
Queen to c2 which is a bit longer after
this check you would get king of three
and now
if you tried checks again you would get
king of to check roof blocks and now you
don't have a good continuation you can
start to advance your pawn but after
rook captures you will get another Queen
enter game but now White has a move
captures with check and after King g5
you'll just move the rook all your
pieces are protected and now white of
course is much much better here the
problem is after this night of 5 what
about Queen to d2 this comes with check
and also attacks the rook so you have to
defend the rook or do you this is what
constant missed and it's also what Fabi
believed that caused and didn't miss so
here you don't guard the rook you play
King of 3 and now black is in huge
product problems if you capture the rook
you get the g4 check and out whatever
you play here either King g5 or g6 you
just get checkmate it so far be missed
Knight to h5 which is really interesting
I think he just didn't even try double
checking as even though Crossen was less
than a minute on the clock Fabi was I
think four four and a half maybe even
five minutes on the clock so not nothing
Fabi can't find I think he just trusted
Magnus in this one so he played Knight
to f3 and here cousin just goes Queen to
see to check with King to h3 and now
crossing again a disgusting engine line
I will not even ask you to find it as
it's impossible I'll just show it
briefly
Magnus played King g6 he wanted to kick
away the rook so he doesn't have any
painting problems here but Queen to b3
is the winning engine line which the
DIDS Queen to g8 after Knight h4 Queen
GA you keep the route back
look the c7 goes after the pawn here and
out night to f7 and now you have
problems like Queen g4 is coming Knight
g5 is coming and if you don't capture
the pawn then black just has an
additional passed pawn and c3 which you
simply cannot allow and if black
captures then you get an ID g5 check
after the key moves and now comes Queen
a to check so really crazy Queen b3
Queen g8 Queen a to check now Knight
blocks and now King g4 and now you have
Queen f2 night
and slowly but surely you will you know
have black will have too many problems
for whites to solve but really really
just interesting for example if you want
to prevent this like rookie fun then you
lose the e4 pawn and again you slowly
but surely black will be will be coming
for white but again with less than a
minute on the clock Magnus missed that
he played King to g6 and now we have
rook the c7 Knights to f7 by cross and
and now Knight to h4 check King g7
Knight a5 check King g6 night h4 check
King g7 and i25 check and it was in this
position I'm all 36 that Fabi and cousin
agreed to a draw as you will either lose
the night if you move the King somewhere
weird or if you go King jet it's just
rook c8 checking h7 and our rock c7
again goes for the night and you will
have a draw by repetition here so really
crazy crazy line Fabi really surprising
Magnus in the opening with that fancy a3
move that wasn't played for almost 20
years and Magnus had to spend more time
so he got in time trouble he missed the
one-shot Fabi gave him but Fabi also
missed the shot that Magnus gave him
it's I don't know you know it's open for
debate whether it's harder to spot night
at 5 over for Queen b3 but I would agree
both are really disgusting engine line
moves but it's interesting after the
game
Magnus short Fabi the line that he
missed although I don't know if he was
if he realizes that he also had a win so
I really just a crazy game but now I
will mention it it's from the classical
time format so there are still the
Armageddon which I will probably be
making after this video so I do hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank
yellow short stack services
Roger Bhattacharjee M Rosetta Greg
Hampton and Remington Roth who had a
birthday yesterday I was playing them
and making another video yesterday so I
was preparing to wish you a happy
birthday yesterday but as I didn't you
know things don't always work out the
way you planned them so very very happy
or 13th birthday I hope you really had a
great party and that you will you know
win a lot of games in the years to come
so once again that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check
too in my previous videos ER thank all
for watching and I will see soon most
likely with the Armageddon game between
these two nice gentlemen but who knows
you know things don't always go the way
you plan thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day